Film Courage: Diego R. writes in “Specifically
for TV, how does one balance giving a satisfying
season (or episode for that matter) plot and
closure with complete character arcs, while
leaving room for a new season that might be
made?”
Peter Russell: Well you don’t want to heal
the wounds, that’s basically it.
You take a show like Animal Planet (Animal
Kingdom?)
Animal Kingdom which is a great show by John
Wells specializing now taking foreign shows
and then turning them into American shows.
You’ve got a matriarch (a poisonous matriarch)
Ellen Barkin and her kids who she’s completely,
massively screwing up constantly.
You know you just never want to have those
kids get better.
And they don’t.
One of them has just been killed and the others
are just as poisonous as they were, they’re
a nest of snakes.
I mean the great thing about television is
you replace healing which is what you get
in a movie with surprise.
So characters don’t change in television,
they surprise with new (often appalling) aspects
to their character you didn’t know about.
Let me ask you this, you probably have someone
you’ve known for 20 years right?
And you know them better and better right?
Film Courage: Uh…some of them.
Peter: And as you get to know them better
and better don’t you find they’re insanely
appalling people the more you know them?
Film Courage: Uh…a few of them!
Yes, that would be an understatement.
Peter: Oh my God!
Oh my God!
They are even worse than I thought.
Film Courage: Yep.
Peter: That’s television.
It’s like “Uh, Dave see you later.
Glad you’re not with your mother anymore.”
You’re learning new things about them…I’m
just using that as an example.
Film Courage: He wasn’t the person I was
thinking of.
Peter: You’re learning new things about
them that shock you.
They’re surprising.
Film Courage: Oh, yes.
Peter: For instance in the SOPRANOS that we
were talking about earlier, Janice is getting
married to a guy named Ritchie and they are
discussing their wedding plans one night and
he gets angry at her and suddenly slaps her
which you’ve never, ever seen him do before.
He’s never been violent to her.
That’s a surprise that Ritchie suddenly
slaps Janice.
It’s not a change in his character, he’s
not getting worse the way you do in a movie
“I’m getting worse because of my wounds.”
He’s just being Ritchie but he’s a surprise.
Then Janice goes to a closet while Ritchie
while he’s sitting there eating his dinner
and she comes out of the closet and she’s
got a gun.
And he goes “C’mon?”
And BOOM!
She shoots him.
Right at the table, okay?
That’s a new surprise from Janice.
You haven’t seen her do that before, right.
Is she healing or getting worse?
No she’s just Janice.
It’s a new revelation of character.
So the way you do it in television is you
keep surprising us with new aspects of a character.
Someone reveals something about themselves
you didn’t know before.
That’s why television is great.
It’s more like real life than movies, right?
It’s just you and your friends learning
more and more appealing things about each
other as you go along.
And they are not things that are going to
make you go “Oh, they’re healing or they’re
getting better.”
It’s like “That’s just horrible.”
And so that’s the big difference between
movies and television, surprise replaces healing.